Hey friends, it's Jillian from the Teach Me How to Adult podcast. If, like me, you're looking to travel more this year and make some extra income on the side, this one is for you. We've teamed up with Airbnb to share more about how to be an Airbnb host because you could be sitting in the perfect Airbnb spot right now. If you have a spare bedroom, which also, side note, is such a fun way to meet new people from around the world, if you're hosting them, why not make some extra money off of it? Or if you're always traveling like I am, it's so easy to just Airbnb your whole place. I was out of town for four months out of the year last year with a vacant condo just sitting there not being used.
Hey friends, it's Jillian from the Teach Me How to Adult podcast. If, like me, you're looking to travel more this year and make some extra income on the side, this one is for you. We've teamed up with Airbnb to share more about how to be an Airbnb host because you could be sitting in the perfect Airbnb spot right now. If you have a spare bedroom, which also, side note, is such a fun way to meet new people from around the world, if you're hosting them, why not make some extra money off of it? Or if you're always traveling like I am, it's so easy to just Airbnb your whole place. I was out of town for four months out of the year last year with a vacant condo just sitting there not being used.|||大家好，我是《教我如何成年》播客的吉莉安。如果你和我一样，希望今年能多去旅行并赚点外快，那么这一期节目绝对适合你。我们与爱彼迎（Airbnb）合作，向大家分享如何成为一名爱彼迎房东，因为你现在可能就坐在完美的爱彼迎房源里。如果你有一间空闲的卧室——顺便说一句，这也是结识来自世界各地新朋友的绝佳方式——既然你都在招待他们了，为什么不顺便赚点外快呢？或者，如果你像我一样经常旅行，把整套房子都挂在爱彼迎上其实非常简单。去年一年里我有四个月都不在本地，空置的公寓就那样闲置着。
And I've realized how easy it would be to make extra money in the side to cover all of my travel costs when I'm away just by becoming an Airbnb host. When I'm traveling the world, I almost exclusively stay in Airbnbs because I like having access to a kitchen, feeling like I'm at home when I'm traveling, having all the stuff that you would normally have when you're at home. And I love the local recommendation guides that a lot of hosts provide. So you can just get to know the area that you're visiting from someone who's actually lived in it. I just used Airbnb actually in Tulum to stay at truly the most luxurious penthouse loft I have I've ever seen. It was such a vibe. The aesthetic was incredible. The service was fantastic. And
And I've realized how easy it would be to make extra money in the side to cover all of my travel costs when I'm away just by becoming an Airbnb host. When I'm traveling the world, I almost exclusively stay in Airbnbs because I like having access to a kitchen, feeling like I'm at home when I'm traveling, having all the stuff that you would normally have when you're at home. And I love the local recommendation guides that a lot of hosts provide. So you can just get to know the area that you're visiting from someone who's actually lived in it. I just used Airbnb actually in Tulum to stay at truly the most luxurious penthouse loft I have I've ever seen. It was such a vibe. The aesthetic was incredible. The service was fantastic. And|||我意识到，只要成为一名爱彼迎房东，在外出时赚取外快来支付所有的旅行费用是多么容易的一件事。当我环游世界时，我几乎只住爱彼迎，因为我喜欢能使用厨房，在旅行时也有在家的感觉，拥有你在家里通常会有的所有东西。而且我很喜欢很多房东提供的本地推荐指南。所以你可以直接通过一个真正住在那儿的人，来了解你正在访问的地区。事实上，我最近在图卢姆就用爱彼迎住过我见过的最豪华的顶层复式公寓。那里的氛围太棒了。美学设计令人惊叹。服务好得没话说。而且
I loved the privacy of it. Airbnb is such a smart way to use what you already have to generate more income, whether you're saving for a wedding or a big trip somewhere, or just trying to cover bills and possibly bump up your income. Your home might be worth more than you think. So find out how much at Airbnb.ca slash host our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis center. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. Case file would like to thank the Queensland Police Homicide Investigation Unit,
I loved the privacy of it. Airbnb is such a smart way to use what you already have to generate more income, whether you're saving for a wedding or a big trip somewhere, or just trying to cover bills and possibly bump up your income. Your home might be worth more than you think. So find out how much at Airbnb.ca slash host our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis center. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. Case file would like to thank the Queensland Police Homicide Investigation Unit,|||我很喜欢它的私密性。爱彼迎是一种非常聪明的赚钱方式，它能利用你已有的资源创造更多收入，无论你是在为婚礼存钱、为某次大旅行攒钱，还是仅仅想支付账单并可能增加收入。你的家可能比你想象的更有价值。访问 Airbnb.ca/host 了解具体价值。我们的节目涉及严重且通常令人痛苦的事件。如果你在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系你当地的危机中心。有关保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看你的应用程序或我们网站上的本期节目shownotes（节目文稿）。《案件档案》（Casefile）要感谢昆士兰警察局凶杀案调查组、
the White Ribbon Foundation, and the family of Leanne Lapham for their assistance and support in creating this episode and highlighting the issues raised. The names of several witnesses have been changed. In 1979, American psychologist Dr. Lenore Walker developed The Cycle of Violence, a theory that explains the patterns of behavior within an abusive relationship. The cycle consists of three phases. The first is tension building, as daily issues like employment, finances, children, illness, and misunderstandings cause pressures within a couple to increase. During this time, verbal, emotional, or financial abuse intensifies to a boiling point where release is inevitable. The cycle then enters the second phase,
the White Ribbon Foundation, and the family of Leanne Lapham for their assistance and support in creating this episode and highlighting the issues raised. The names of several witnesses have been changed. In 1979, American psychologist Dr. Lenore Walker developed The Cycle of Violence, a theory that explains the patterns of behavior within an abusive relationship. The cycle consists of three phases. The first is tension building, as daily issues like employment, finances, children, illness, and misunderstandings cause pressures within a couple to increase. During this time, verbal, emotional, or financial abuse intensifies to a boiling point where release is inevitable. The cycle then enters the second phase,|||白丝带基金会（White Ribbon Foundation）以及利安·拉帕姆（Leanne Lapham）的家人，感谢他们在制作本期节目以及强调所提出问题方面提供的协助和支持。几位证人的名字已被更改。1979年，美国心理学家勒诺·沃克（Lenore Walker）博士提出了“暴力循环”（The Cycle of Violence），这是一个解释虐待关系中行为模式的理论。这个循环包括三个阶段。第一阶段是紧张升级（tension building），随着就业、财务、孩子、疾病和误解等日常问题导致伴侣之间的压力不断增加。在此期间，言语、情感或经济上的虐待加剧，直至达到不可避免要宣泄的沸点。随后，循环进入第二阶段，
acute explosion. Abuse peaks as the abuser establishes their dominance through action. Following this, they may express feelings of remorse or shame, perhaps bearing their partner may leave or report them to authorities. They try to justify their actions by blaming external factors before seeking forgiveness, sometimes threatening self-harm to gain sympathy. It's during this final stage, known as the honeymoon, where the abuser promises to change and displays an unusual amount of love and affection. The survivor is distressed, hurt, confused, and humiliated, yet hopeful the relationship will improve if they give their partner another chance.
acute explosion. Abuse peaks as the abuser establishes their dominance through action. Following this, they may express feelings of remorse or shame, perhaps bearing their partner may leave or report them to authorities. They try to justify their actions by blaming external factors before seeking forgiveness, sometimes threatening self-harm to gain sympathy. It's during this final stage, known as the honeymoon, where the abuser promises to change and displays an unusual amount of love and affection. The survivor is distressed, hurt, confused, and humiliated, yet hopeful the relationship will improve if they give their partner another chance.|||急性爆发（acute explosion）。随着施虐者通过实际行动确立其统治地位，虐待达到顶峰。在此之后，他们可能会表达悔恨或羞耻感，也许是担心伴侣会离开或向当局举报他们。他们在寻求原谅之前，试图通过指责外部因素来为自己的行为辩护，有时甚至以自残相威胁来博取同情。正是在这个被称为蜜月期（honeymoon）的最后阶段，施虐者承诺改变，并表现出异常的关爱和温情。幸存者感到痛苦、受伤、困惑和羞辱，但仍怀抱希望，只要给伴侣另一次机会，这段关系就会改善。
The pair then enter a stage of denial, downplaying the severity or refusing to acknowledge the abuse, answering a period of harmony and intimacy. This stage can be short-lived or long-lasting before the cycle repeats itself. The situated on North Queensland's Cassowary Coast is Innisvale, a township of approximately 10,000 residents surrounded by farmland and old-growth rainforests. Heavy rainfall coupled with an average daytime temperature of around 30 degrees Celsius keeps the area lush and green all year, supporting an agricultural industry of sugarcane, bananas, and other tropical fruits.
The pair then enter a stage of denial, downplaying the severity or refusing to acknowledge the abuse, answering a period of harmony and intimacy. This stage can be short-lived or long-lasting before the cycle repeats itself. The situated on North Queensland's Cassowary Coast is Innisvale, a township of approximately 10,000 residents surrounded by farmland and old-growth rainforests. Heavy rainfall coupled with an average daytime temperature of around 30 degrees Celsius keeps the area lush and green all year, supporting an agricultural industry of sugarcane, bananas, and other tropical fruits.|||随后，两人进入否认阶段，淡化严重程度或拒绝承认虐待行为，迎来了和谐与亲密的时期。这个阶段可能短暂，也可能持久，然后循环就会重复。位于北昆士兰卡索阿拉海岸（Cassowary Coast）的是尼斯维尔（Innisfail），这是一个拥有约1万名居民的小镇，四周环绕着农田和原始雨林。充沛的降雨量加上30摄氏度左右的平均白天气温，使该地区全年郁郁葱葱、绿意盎然，支持着甘蔗、香蕉和其他热带水果的农业。
By 2009, 29-year-old Leanne Maxine Lapham had relocated to Innisvale to be closer to her family. She shared an unbreakable bond with her mother, Kerry, although their personalities often clashed. Kerry believed this had less to do with animosity and more to do with astrology. Leanne's star sign was Pisces, sensitive, intuitive, creative, and emotionally driven. Kerry was a Capricorn, confident, practical, hard-working, and determined. Leanne also had bipolar disorder. Although her mood was unpredictable at times, Kerry remained a pillar of support, and the pair shared more good times than bad. Leanne was good fun. Whenever she saw an opportunity to get a rise out of her mother,
By 2009, 29-year-old Leanne Maxine Lapham had relocated to Innisvale to be closer to her family. She shared an unbreakable bond with her mother, Kerry, although their personalities often clashed. Kerry believed this had less to do with animosity and more to do with astrology. Leanne's star sign was Pisces, sensitive, intuitive, creative, and emotionally driven. Kerry was a Capricorn, confident, practical, hard-working, and determined. Leanne also had bipolar disorder. Although her mood was unpredictable at times, Kerry remained a pillar of support, and the pair shared more good times than bad. Leanne was good fun. Whenever she saw an opportunity to get a rise out of her mother,|||到2009年，29岁的利安·玛克辛·拉帕姆（Leanne Maxine Lapham）已搬到尼斯维尔，以便离家人更近。她与母亲克里（Kerry）有着密不可分的纽带，尽管两人的性格经常冲突。克里认为这与敌意关系不大，更多是与占星术有关。利安的星座是双鱼座，敏感、直觉敏锐、有创造力且受情感驱动。克里则是摩羯座，自信、务实、勤奋且坚定。利安还患有双相情感障碍。尽管她的情绪有时难以预测，但克里一直是她坚强的后盾，两人在一起度过的好时光多于坏时光。利安很有趣。每当她看到能激怒母亲的机会时，
her mischievous side would come out. During a shopping centre visit, Leanne started tap dancing, much to Kerry's embarrassment. Her mother's mortification only encouraged Leanne, as a passerby asked, isn't it lovely to see somebody so happy? To which Leanne replied, I just love my mummy. Joking they were running away from home, the two set out on a road trip, heading south with the windows down and a music blaring. Leanne was at the wheel when slippery conditions caused the vehicle to spin and hit a dirt mound on the roadside. Leanne was hesitant to get back behind the wheel, so they checked into a caravan park for the night. Their assigned caravan was perched on a hilltop above a busy highway,
her mischievous side would come out. During a shopping centre visit, Leanne started tap dancing, much to Kerry's embarrassment. Her mother's mortification only encouraged Leanne, as a passerby asked, isn't it lovely to see somebody so happy? To which Leanne replied, I just love my mummy. Joking they were running away from home, the two set out on a road trip, heading south with the windows down and a music blaring. Leanne was at the wheel when slippery conditions caused the vehicle to spin and hit a dirt mound on the roadside. Leanne was hesitant to get back behind the wheel, so they checked into a caravan park for the night. Their assigned caravan was perched on a hilltop above a busy highway,|||她淘气的一面就会显露出来。在一次逛商场时，利安跳起了踢踏舞，弄得克里十分尴尬。母亲的窘迫反而更加鼓励了利安，这时一个路人问：“看到有人这么快乐，不是很美好吗？”利安回答说：“我就是爱我的妈咪。”两人开玩笑说要离家出走，于是踏上了公路旅行，摇下车窗，放着震耳欲聋的音乐向南驶去。路面湿滑导致车辆打转并撞上了路边的土堆时，利安正坐在驾驶座上。利安犹豫着不敢再开车，于是他们登记入住了一个房车公园过夜。他们分到的房车坐落在一条繁忙高速公路上方的小山丘上，
prompting Leanne to taunt her mother with comments like, wouldn't it be horrible if we started rolling down the hill? Although it could drive her mad, Kerry embraced Leanne's playful personality. In Innisfail, Leanne was staying between Kerry and her partner Frank's house and a detached room at the home of a family friend, 57-year-old Augie. Augie lived on a wrecking yard that serviced his business, Mundu Towing. Leanne was searching for somewhere more permanent while doing occasional bar work and tattooing. She had several of her own, a jester on her right shoulder, a woodpecker on her stomach,
prompting Leanne to taunt her mother with comments like, wouldn't it be horrible if we started rolling down the hill? Although it could drive her mad, Kerry embraced Leanne's playful personality. In Innisfail, Leanne was staying between Kerry and her partner Frank's house and a detached room at the home of a family friend, 57-year-old Augie. Augie lived on a wrecking yard that serviced his business, Mundu Towing. Leanne was searching for somewhere more permanent while doing occasional bar work and tattooing. She had several of her own, a jester on her right shoulder, a woodpecker on her stomach,|||这促使利安对母亲冷嘲热讽，说出诸如“如果我们开始朝山下滚下去，那不是太可怕了吗？”之类的话。尽管利安有时会把她逼疯，但克里还是接受了利安顽皮的性格。在尼斯维尔，利安住在克里及其伴侣弗兰克（Frank）的房子，以及家庭朋友、57岁的奥吉（Augie）家的一间独立房间之间。奥吉住在经营他业务（芒杜拖车公司 Mundu Towing）的废车场里。利安在寻找更固定住所的同时，偶尔做点酒吧工作和纹身。她自己身上有几个纹身：右肩膀上有一个小丑，肚子上有一只啄木鸟，
several flowers and stars on her legs, and the name of her daughter, who was currently living with her father, on her left wrist. Hoping to make a career of it, Leanne would practice her art on friends and family, including inking a flower on Kerry's right calf. In early 2009, Leanne was at Kerry and Frank's house when Frank invited over one of his workmates, 36-year-old Graham Evans. The former butcher turned to laborer had recently moved to Queensland from New South Wales, settling in Innisfail, where he worked as a self-employed painter. When he laid eyes on Leanne, Evans felt an immediate attraction and wasn't shy
several flowers and stars on her legs, and the name of her daughter, who was currently living with her father, on her left wrist. Hoping to make a career of it, Leanne would practice her art on friends and family, including inking a flower on Kerry's right calf. In early 2009, Leanne was at Kerry and Frank's house when Frank invited over one of his workmates, 36-year-old Graham Evans. The former butcher turned to laborer had recently moved to Queensland from New South Wales, settling in Innisfail, where he was working as a self-employed painter. When he laid eyes on Leanne, Evans felt an immediate attraction and wasn't shy|||腿上有几朵花和星星，左手腕上纹着她目前和父亲住在一起的女儿的名字。利安希望能把这门手艺当成职业，便在朋友和家人身上练习她的艺术，包括在克里的右小腿上纹了一朵花。2009年初，利安在克里和弗兰克的家里，当时弗兰克邀请了他的一个同事、36岁的格雷厄姆·埃文斯（Graham Evans）来做客。这位由屠夫转行当体力劳动者的男子最近从新南威尔士州搬到了昆士兰，在尼斯维尔安家，并做着自雇油漆工的工作。当埃文斯看到利安时，他顿时产生了吸引力，也毫不掩饰
telling Kerry his feelings. Protective of Leanne, she warned him that it was her daughter he was talking about. Evans excused himself to use the bathroom, but went to speak with Leanne instead, inviting her on a date that evening. Evans maintained a level of stability and charm that separated him from other men around town, until Leanne returned from their date, smitten. Kerry cautioned her to take things slow, but the two quickly became a couple. There's was a rocky relationship from the outset, with the erratic Evans often lashing out at Leanne. Kerry felt it wasn't going to work, but Leanne excused his behaviour by saying, Mum, he's really nice, he just gets angry. The pair fluctuated between contentment and
telling Kerry his feelings. Protective of Leanne, she warned him that it was her daughter he was talking about. Evans excused himself to use the bathroom, but went to speak with Leanne instead, inviting her on a date that evening. Evans maintained a level of stability and charm that separated him from other men around town, until Leanne returned from their date, smitten. Kerry cautioned her to take things slow, but the two quickly became a couple. There's was a rocky relationship from the outset, with the erratic Evans often lashing out at Leanne. Kerry felt it wasn't going to work, but Leanne excused his behaviour by saying, Mum, he's really nice, he just gets angry. The pair fluctuated between contentment and|||他对克里的感觉。出于对利安的保护，克里警告他，他谈论的是她的女儿。埃文斯借口去洗手间，但实际上是去跟利安说话，并邀请她当晚约会。埃文斯表现出了一种稳定感和魅力，使他区别于镇上的其他男人，直到利安约会回来后，已经神魂颠倒。克里警告她慢慢来，但两人很快就确立了恋爱关系。从一开始，这段关系就充满波折，喜怒无常的埃文斯经常对利安大发雷霆。克里觉得这样行不通，但利安为他的行为辩解道：“妈妈，他人真的很好，只是有时会发脾气。”两人在满足与
disharmony, with Leanne's threats to leave causing Evans to beg for forgiveness, declare his love, and promise to treat her better. In September 2009, Leanne fell pregnant, determined to raise her child in a stable, two-parent household. She believed Evans when he expressed to joy and eagerness at starting a family. Yet, his behaviour remained violent and unpredictable, causing Leanne to break things off, only to resume their relationship when Evans expressed remorse. In early 2010, when Leanne was heavily pregnant, she and Evans travelled 16 kilometres north to camp at Ella Bay. An argument broke out, and Evans slapped Leanne, snatched her handbag, and pushed her out of the car. He slammed her legs in the door before driving
disharmony, with Leanne's threats to leave causing Evans to beg for forgiveness, declare his love, and promise to treat her better. In September 2009, Leanne fell pregnant, determined to raise her child in a stable, two-parent household. She believed Evans when he expressed to joy and eagerness at starting a family. Yet, his behaviour remained violent and unpredictable, causing Leanne to break things off, only to resume their relationship when Evans expressed remorse. In early 2010, when Leanne was heavily pregnant, she and Evans travelled 16 kilometres north to camp at Ella Bay. An argument broke out, and Evans slapped Leanne, snatched her handbag, and pushed her out of the car. He slammed her legs in the door before driving|||不和谐之间摇摆不定，利安提出要离开的威胁导致埃文斯苦苦哀求原谅、表白爱意并承诺对她更好。2009年9月，利安怀孕了，决心在一个稳定的双亲家庭中抚养她的孩子。当埃文斯表达出建立家庭的喜悦和渴望时，她相信了。然而，他的行为依然暴力且不可预测，导致利安提出分手，但每当埃文斯表现出悔意时，他们又复合了。2010年初，当利安身怀六甲时，她和埃文斯向北行驶16公里到埃拉湾（Ella Bay）露营。两人爆发了争吵，埃文斯打了利安一巴掌，抢走她的手提包，并将她推下车。他在关车门时夹住了她的双腿，然后开车
away. Severely bruised on both legs, face and arms, Leanne walked to her payphone and called her mother in tears. Her taxi was ordered to pick her up. Kerry knew Evans was verbally abusive and called her daughter names, but Leanne assured everything was fine. When she saw the injuries Evans caused, Kerry encouraged Leanne to file a police report, and she obtained a medical certificate to corroborate it. On March 15, Leanne was scheduled to appear at the Innisfail Magistrates Court to apply for a domestic violence order against Evans, who had no prior criminal record, citing intimidation, harassment, and verbal and physical threats. However, she had to leave before the application
away. Severely bruised on both legs, face and arms, Leanne walked to her payphone and called her mother in tears. Her taxi was ordered to pick her up. Kerry knew Evans was verbally abusive and called her daughter names, but Leanne assured everything was fine. When she saw the injuries Evans caused, Kerry encouraged Leanne to file a police report, and she obtained a medical certificate to corroborate it. On March 15, Leanne was scheduled to appear at the Innisfail Magistrates Court to apply for a domestic violence order against Evans, who had no prior criminal record, citing intimidation, harassment, and verbal and physical threats. However, she had to leave before the application|||扬长而去。利安的双腿、脸部和手臂都严重淤青，她走到公用电话亭，哭着给母亲打了电话。她的出租车被叫去接她。克里知道埃文斯有言语虐待并辱骂她的女儿，但利安向她保证一切都好。当克里看到埃文斯造成的伤势时，她鼓励利安去报警，并取得了一份医疗证明来佐证。3月15日，利安原定出席尼斯维尔地方法院，申请针对埃文斯的家庭暴力禁令（埃文斯没有犯罪前科），理由是恐吓、骚扰以及言语和身体威胁。然而，她在申请
was filed to attend an anti-natal class. The order was adjourned until April 13. On March 21, Leanne sent a text message to a longtime friend, Matt, who lived in Brisbane. She was fed up with Innisfail and had plans to leave town if the judge didn't issue the domestic violence order against Evans. He had recently threatened to steal the baby from her, or failing that, take it by force. She detailed how Evans showed up unannounced at her mother's house and refused to leave. He verbally abused Leanne, causing her to lose her temper. She wrote to Matt, I got so angry that I put Bub in danger. That's real bad. I'm angry at myself. The Innisfail Department of Community's Child Safety and Disability Services contacted Leanne
was filed to attend an anti-natal class. The order was adjourned until April 13. On March 21, Leanne sent a text message to a longtime friend, Matt, who lived in Brisbane. She was fed up with Innisfail and had plans to leave town if the judge didn't issue the domestic violence order against Evans. He had recently threatened to steal the baby from her, or failing that, take it by force. She detailed how Evans showed up unannounced at her mother's house and refused to leave. He verbally abused Leanne, causing her to lose her temper. She wrote to Matt, I got so angry that I put Bub in danger. That's real bad. I'm angry at myself. The Innisfail Department of Community's Child Safety and Disability Services contacted Leanne|||提交前不得不离开去参加产前班。该禁令被推迟到4月13日。3月21日，利安给住在布里斯班的老朋友马特（Matt）发了一条短信。她对尼斯维尔感到厌烦，如果法官没有对埃文斯发出家庭暴力禁令，她就计划离开小镇。他最近威胁要从她身边偷走孩子，如果不行就强行抢走。她详细讲述了埃文斯如何不请自来地出现在她母亲家并拒绝离开。他对利安进行言语虐待，导致她发脾气。她写信给马特：“我太生气了，以至于把宝宝置于危险之中。这真的很糟糕。我很生自己的气。”尼斯维尔社区儿童安全与残疾服务部联系了利安
on March 22, amid concerns for her unborn child's welfare. Leanne reported that her relationship with Evans had ended. She also intended to obtain the domestic violence order, referencing the threats he'd made. The department then contacted Graham Evans, who said that he had no intention of resuming the relationship, citing Leanne's bipolar disorder and their constant arguing. Kerry didn't see Evans for a few weeks and assumed the domestic violence order had been filed and the relationship was over. On March 24, 2010, Leanne gave birth to a boy named Bradley James Lapham. Evans visited them in hospital, promising to change and provide for his family. Leanne was reluctant, but agreed to get back together if he delivered on his promises.
on March 22, amid concerns for her unborn child's welfare. Leanne reported that her relationship with Evans had ended. She also intended to obtain the domestic violence order, referencing the threats he'd made. The department then contacted Graham Evans, who said that he had no intention of resuming the relationship, citing Leanne's bipolar disorder and their constant arguing. Kerry didn't see Evans for a few weeks and assumed the domestic violence order had been filed and the relationship was over. On March 24, 2010, Leanne gave birth to a boy named Bradley James Lapham. Evans visited them in hospital, promising to change and provide for his family. Leanne was reluctant, but agreed to get back together if he delivered on his promises.|||3月22日，出于对她腹中胎儿福利的担忧。利安报告说她与埃文斯的关系已经结束。她还打算获得家庭暴力禁令，并提及了他曾做出的威胁。随后，该部门联系了格雷厄姆·埃文斯，后者表示他无意恢复这段关系，并以利安的双相情感障碍和他们不断的争吵为由。克里有几周没见到埃文斯了，以为家庭暴力禁令已经提交，关系已经结束。2010年3月24日，利安生下了一个名叫布拉德利·詹姆斯·拉帕姆（Bradley James Lapham）的男孩。埃文斯去医院看望了他们，承诺会改变并养家糊口。利安有些勉强，但同意如果他兑现承诺就复合。
When her mother questioned Leanne's decision, she responded that she loved Evans and wanted to make things work for Bradley. The couple found an ideal family home, a spacious three-bedroom house surrounded by greenery 22 kilometers south of Innisfail, but it wasn't available until later in the month. Evans sent Leanne a text promising to fund a motel room for them in the meantime, writing, I swear that, Leanne, I will do anything to make that happen. I'm not losing you. If I can not, then I'm no man. I will get us out of this shit. I need your love, Leanne, and I will get it. The next morning, he secured a one-week stay at the Riverside Motel in the town center, where he and Leanne had stayed on prior occasions, and on April 13, the trio settled in.
When her mother questioned Leanne's decision, she responded that she loved Evans and wanted to make things work for Bradley. The couple found an ideal family home, a spacious three-bedroom house surrounded by greenery 22 kilometers south of Innisfail, but it wasn't available until later in the month. Evans sent Leanne a text promising to fund a motel room for them in the meantime, writing, I swear that, Leanne, I will do anything to make that happen. I'm not losing you. If I can not, then I'm no man. I will get us out of this shit. I need your love, Leanne, and I will get it. The next morning, he secured a one-week stay at the Riverside Motel in the town center, where he and Leanne had stayed on prior occasions, and on April 13, the trio settled in.|||当母亲质疑利安的决定时，她回答说她爱埃文斯，并希望为了布拉德利让这段感情维持下去。这对夫妇找到了一个理想的家庭住宅——一栋位于尼斯维尔以南22公里处、四周绿树环绕的宽敞三居室房子，但这套房子要到本月晚些时候才能入住。埃文斯给利安发了一条短信，承诺在此期间资助他们住汽车旅馆，他写道：“我发誓，利安，为了实现这一点我什么都愿意做。我不会失去你的。如果我做不到，那我就不算个男人。我会带我们脱离这个烂摊子。我需要你的爱，利安，我会得到的。”第二天早上，他在市中心的河畔汽车旅馆（Riverside Motel）预订了一周的住宿（他和利安以前曾住过这里），4月13日，三人在那里安顿下来。
Leanne failed to appear in court to complete her domestic violence order against Evans, seemingly eager to start afresh. But this honeymoon period was only temporary. By the evening of April 15, the pair were fighting again. Evans was failing to live up to his promises, arriving home late, drinking too much, and rumors had spread of his alleged infidelity. He urged Leanne to be strong and persevere for Bradley's sake. At 10 a.m. on Monday, April 19, Evans dropped Leanne and Bradley at Kerry's house, a three-minute drive from the Riverside Motel. Leanne and Kerry ran some errands in town, including a visit to Bendigo Bank, where Leanne withdrew $100. They entered the Cole
Leanne failed to appear in court to complete her domestic violence order against Evans, seemingly eager to start afresh. But this honeymoon period was only temporary. By the evening of April 15, the pair were fighting again. Evans was failing to live up to his promises, arriving home late, drinking too much, and rumors had spread of his alleged infidelity. He urged Leanne to be strong and persevere for Bradley's sake. At 10 a.m. on Monday, April 19, Evans dropped Leanne and Bradley at Kerry's house, a three-minute drive from the Riverside Motel. Leanne and Kerry ran some errands in town, including a visit to Bendigo Bank, where Leanne withdrew $100. They entered the Cole|||利安未能出庭完成针对埃文斯的家庭暴力禁令申请，似乎急于重新开始。但这段蜜月期只是暂时的。到了4月15日晚上，两人又开始吵架了。埃文斯没有兑现他的承诺，回家很晚，酒喝得太多，而且有关于他疑似不忠的传言传开。他敦促利安要坚强，为了布拉德利的缘故坚持下去。4月19日星期一上午10点，埃文斯将利安和布拉德利送到克里的家（距离河畔汽车旅馆有三分钟的车程）。利安和克里在镇上办了一些差事，包括去本迪戈银行（Bendigo Bank），利安在那里取了100澳元。他们走进科尔斯（Coles）
supermarket, where Leanne purchased food for dinner. She sent Evans a text suggesting she cooked a seafood basket or creamy sauce, and reminded him to pick her up for a three-o-clock post-pernatal appointment. He responded, Sounds good, hun. See you then. Evans arrived after 3 p.m., and Leanne, irritated by his tardiness, silently climbed in to his white 1994 Holden rodeo ute, and the pair took off. At 2.30 p.m. the next day, Evans' friend, Sam, arrived home to find Evans and baby Bradley at his house. Evans' ute was packed full of gear, and he asked to stay the night, saying, She's left me with the baby and gone off. He explained that the night before, Leanne was angry at him for being late and slapped a beer
supermarket, where Leanne purchased food for dinner. She sent Evans a text suggesting she cooked a seafood basket or creamy sauce, and reminded him to pick her up for a three-o-clock post-pernatal appointment. He responded, Sounds good, hun. See you then. Evans arrived after 3 p.m., and Leanne, irritated by his tardiness, silently climbed in to his white 1994 Holden rodeo ute, and the pair took off. At 2.30 p.m. the next day, Evans' friend, Sam, arrived home to find Evans and baby Bradley at his house. Evans' ute was packed full of gear, and he asked to stay the night, saying, She's left me with the baby and gone off. He explained that the night before, Leanne was angry at him for being late and slapped a beer|||超市，利安在那里买了晚餐的食物。她给埃文斯发了一条短信，建议她做海鲜拼盘或奶油酱，并提醒他来接她去下午三点的产后复查。他回复道：“听起来不错，亲爱的。到时见。”埃文斯在下午3点以后才到，利安对他的迟到感到恼火，默默地爬上了他那辆白色的1994款霍顿罗德奥（Holden Rodeo）皮卡，两人驱车离开。第二天下午2点30分，埃文斯的朋友山姆（Sam）回到家，发现埃文斯和婴儿布拉德利在他的房子里。埃文斯的皮卡车里塞满了装备，他请求留宿一晚，说道：“她把孩子扔给我，自己跑了。”他解释说，前天晚上，利安因为他迟到而生气，打掉了一瓶啤酒
out of his hand then stormed out of their motel room. Evans assumed she was blowing off steam and would return later, but she never did. Two days later, on April 22, Leanne's sister received a phone call from Evans. He said Leanne had gone to Cairns, a coastal city 80km north of Innisvale, to visit a friend who had just given birth, and texted him saying she would be home later that evening. Meanwhile, Kerry had noticed that Leanne wasn't responding to texts or answering calls. She phoned Evans, who claimed Leanne had her mobile phone with her in Cairns, but he hadn't heard from her at all. While it wasn't unusual for her daughter to travel to
out of his hand then stormed out of their motel room. Evans assumed she was blowing off steam and would return later, but she never did. Two days later, on April 22, Leanne's sister received a phone call from Evans. He said Leanne had gone to Cairns, a coastal city 80km north of Innisvale, to visit a friend who had just given birth, and texted him saying she would be home later that evening. Meanwhile, Kerry had noticed that Leanne wasn't responding to texts or answering calls. She phoned Evans, who claimed Leanne had her mobile phone with her in Cairns, but he hadn't heard from her at all. While it wasn't unusual for her daughter to travel to|||，然后气冲冲地跑出了他们的汽车旅馆房间。埃文斯以为她在宣泄情绪，一会儿就会回来，但她再也没有回来。两天后，即4月22日，利安的妹妹接到了埃文斯的电话。他说利安去了尼斯维尔以北80公里的沿海城市凯恩斯（Cairns），去探望一个刚生完孩子的朋友，并给她发短信说当天晚些时候会回家。与此同时，克里注意到利安没有回复短信，也没有接听电话。她打电话给埃文斯，埃文斯声称利安带着手机去了凯恩斯，但他根本没有听到她的任何消息。虽然女儿去旅行
visit friends, Kerry knew Leanne would not elect to leave her newborn in the care of Graham Evans. Over the following days, Evans spoke to friends about Leanne's departure, telling some she would return within the week and others that she wasn't coming back at all. On April 28, Kerry arrived to Innisvale police station to file a missing person's report. To the best of her knowledge, Leanne didn't owe anyone money and was well-liked within her social circle. She detailed Graham Evans' abusive behaviour, including an incident on Leanne's birthday when he threw a hot drink at her, burning her skin. Bank records revealed Leanne hadn't accessed her account since the day she allegedly left the motel
visit friends, Kerry knew Leanne would not elect to leave her newborn in the care of Graham Evans. Over the following days, Evans spoke to friends about Leanne's departure, telling some she would return within the week and others that she wasn't coming back at all. On April 28, Kerry arrived to Innisvale police station to file a missing person's report. To the best of her knowledge, Leanne didn't owe anyone money and was well-liked within her social circle. She detailed Graham Evans' abusive behaviour, including an incident on Leanne's birthday when he threw a hot drink at her, burning her skin. Bank records revealed Leanne hadn't accessed her account since the day she allegedly left the motel|||拜访朋友并不罕见，但克里知道利安绝不会选择将刚出生的婴儿交给格雷厄姆·埃文斯照顾。在随后的几天里，埃文斯对朋友们谈到利安的离开，对一些人说她会在一周内回来，对另一些人则说她根本不会回来了。4月28日，克里来到尼斯维尔警察局报案失踪。据她所知，利安没有欠任何人钱，在她的社交圈里也很受欢迎。她详细描述了格雷厄姆·埃文斯的虐待行为，包括在利安生日那天他把热饮泼在她身上、烫伤她皮肤的一起事件。银行记录显示，自从她据称离开汽车旅馆那天起，利安就再也没有访问过她的账户。
alone. Graham Evans provided a statement to police in which he attested that he had not heard from Leanne since April 19 and had no knowledge of her current whereabouts. He claimed she had gone to the supermarket that night to get more dinner ingredients and returned a short time later with a white plastic bag tucked in her brown handbag. Between 7.30 and 8.00 pm, Leanne grabbed her handbag and walked out the door without saying a word. She hadn't reappeared by the next day and wasn't responding to messages. Despite having extended their stay for one more night, Evans checked out of the motel with Bradley and went to stay at his friend Sam's house, convinced Leanne had left him for good.
alone. Graham Evans provided a statement to police in which he attested that he had not heard from Leanne since April 19 and had no knowledge of her current whereabouts. He claimed she had gone to the supermarket that night to get more dinner ingredients and returned a short time later with a white plastic bag tucked in her brown handbag. Between 7.30 and 8.00 pm, Leanne grabbed her handbag and walked out the door without saying a word. She hadn't reappeared by the next day and wasn't responding to messages. Despite having extended their stay for one more night, Evans checked out of the motel with Bradley and went to stay at his friend Sam's house, convinced Leanne had left him for good.|||格雷厄姆·埃文斯向警方提供了一份陈述，他在其中证实，自4月19日以来，他没有听到过利安的消息，也不知道她目前的下落。他声称她那天晚上去了超市买更多的晚餐食材，不久后拿着一个塞在她棕色手提包里的白色塑料袋回来了。晚上7点30分到8点之间，利安抓起手提包，一言不发地走出了门。到第二天她还没有出现，也没有回复信息。尽管已经续住了一晚，埃文斯还是带着布拉德利退了房，去朋友山姆家住，确信利安已经永远离开了他。
Evans admitted he and Leanne had a volatile relationship but denied the Ella Bay car door incident, explaining, he described Leanne as headstrong and that her bipolar disorder caused her to become easily upset and moody. In the week leading up to her disappearance, Leanne threatened to end their relationship and to leave town but the pair managed to patch things up. Evans claimed that she, quote, would always go and come back. Evans handed his mobile phone to police with text messages between him and Leanne displaying a clear cycle. Conversations switched between affectionate banter and chit chat before an argument would take place. Leanne would express her disappointment with Evans and give him the
Evans admitted he and Leanne had a volatile relationship but denied the Ella Bay car door incident, explaining, he described Leanne as headstrong and that her bipolar disorder caused her to become easily upset and moody. In the week leading up to her disappearance, Leanne threatened to end their relationship and to leave town but the pair managed to patch things up. Evans claimed that she, quote, would always go and come back. Evans handed his mobile phone to police with text messages between him and Leanne displaying a clear cycle. Conversations switched between affectionate banter and chit chat before an argument would take place. Leanne would express her disappointment with Evans and give him the|||埃文斯承认他和利安的关系很不稳定，但否认了埃拉湾车门事件，并解释说，他形容利安性格固执，她的双相情感障碍导致她容易心烦意乱、情绪多变。在失踪前的头一周里，利安威胁要结束他们的关系并离开小镇，但两人设法修补了关系。埃文斯声称她“总是去而复返”。埃文斯将手机交给了警方，他和利安之间的短信显示出一个清晰的循环。对话在亲密的打情骂俏和小憩闲聊之间切换，然后争吵就会发生。利安会表达她对埃文斯的失望，并给他
opportunity to end the relationship but he begged her to stay. On April 10th, Evans texted Leanne how much you loved her and was thankful for the chance to make things right. The next night, he wrote, Love you with all my heart. I am so mad with myself for letting it end up like this. I can make it right and that's what this man will do hun. I swear. By April 17th, tensions escalated once more. Leanne told Evans she had booked a flight and was leaving for good as he pleaded with her to reconsider. Leanne insisted they were better off apart and Evans responded by swearing on their son's life that he would never snap at her again, asking her to let him love her. By April 19th, things seemed to have improved as they texted
opportunity to end the relationship but he begged her to stay. On April 10th, Evans texted Leanne how much you loved her and was thankful for the chance to make things right. The next night, he wrote, Love you with all my heart. I am so mad with myself for letting it end up like this. I can make it right and that's what this man will do hun. I swear. By April 17th, tensions tensions escalated once more. Leanne told Evans she had booked a flight and was leaving for good as he pleaded with her to reconsider. Leanne insisted they were better off apart and Evans responded by swearing on their son's life that he would never snap at her again, asking her to let him love her. By April 19th, things seemed to have improved as they texted|||结束这段关系的机会，但他苦苦哀求她留下来。4月10日，埃文斯发短信给利安，表达他有多么爱她，并感谢有机会弥补一切。第二天晚上，他写道：“我全心全意地爱你。我对自己让事情变成这样感到非常生气的。我能把它纠正过来，亲爱的，这个男人会这么做的。我发誓。”到了4月17日，紧张局势再次升级。利安告诉埃文斯她已经订好了机票，要彻底离开，而他则恳求她重新考虑。利安坚持认为分开对两人都好，埃文斯则发誓以他们儿子的生命起誓，他再也不会对她发脾气，并请求她让他去爱她。到了4月19日，事情似乎有所改善，他们在整个下午都在发短信交流
dinner plans throughout the afternoon until they were back together at the motel room. There was silence until 10.35pm when Leanne's mobile received a text from Evans letting her know that he had fed the baby and gone to sleep. She did not reply. Over the following days of Leanne's disappearance, Evans texted her to get in touch, offering to pick her up wherever she had gone and sending her his love. She did not respond. Detectives were unconvinced Leanne would willingly leave her four-week-old son and were immediately suspicious about Evans. A search of the couple's three-bedroom house that they planned to move into and their former room at the Riverside Motel uncovered no signs of foul play.
dinner plans throughout the afternoon until they were back together at the motel room. There was silence until 10.35pm when Leanne's mobile received a text from Evans letting her know that he had fed the baby and gone to sleep. She did not reply. Over the following days of Leanne's disappearance, Evans texted her to get in touch, offering to pick her up wherever she had gone and sending her his love. She did not respond. Detectives were unconvinced Leanne would willingly leave her four-week-old son and were immediately suspicious about Evans. A search of the couple's three-bedroom house that they planned to move into and their former room at the Riverside Motel uncovered no signs of foul play.|||晚餐计划，直到他们在汽车旅馆的房间里重聚。一片寂静，直到晚上10点35分，利安的手机收到了一条来自埃文斯的短信，告知她他已经喂了孩子并睡了。她没有回复。在利安失踪后的几天里，埃文斯给她发短信让她联系他，并提出无论她去了哪里都可以去接她，还向她表达了爱意。她没有回复。侦探们不相信利安会心甘情愿地离开她四周大的儿子，并立即对埃文斯产生了怀疑。搜查这对夫妇计划搬进去的那栋三居室房子以及他们在河畔汽车旅馆的旧房间时，没有发现任何谋杀或犯罪的迹象。
The Motel manager revealed that during a previous stay in 2009, Leanne and Evans were heard arguing, followed by smashing glass. Leanne called out for help, but the fight dissipated soon after. During their recent Motel booking in mid-April, Evans approached the manager at around lunchtime on the 19th, requesting to stay an extra week. Citing their disruptive behaviour, the manager only agreed to an additional day and at around 4.30pm, cited Leanne smoking outside. That was the last he saw of her and there had been no reports of disputes or suspicious activity immediately prior or after her disappearance. At 8am the next morning, the manager noticed Evans' ute wasn't in the parking lot. It reappeared at around 1pm, parked near the
The Motel manager revealed that during a previous stay in 2009, Leanne and Evans were heard arguing, followed by smashing glass. Leanne called out for help, but the fight dissipated soon after. During their recent Motel booking in mid-April, Evans approached the manager at around lunchtime on the 19th, requesting to stay an extra week. Citing their disruptive behaviour, the manager only agreed to an additional day and at around 4.30pm, cited Leanne smoking outside. That was the last he saw of her and there had been no reports of disputes or suspicious activity immediately prior or after her disappearance. At 8am the next morning, the manager noticed Evans' ute wasn't in the parking lot. It reappeared at around 1pm, parked near the|||汽车旅馆经理透露，在2009年的一次入住期间，有人听到利安和埃文斯在争吵，随后是玻璃破碎的声音。利安大声呼救，但争吵很快就平息了。在4月中旬最近的一次汽车旅馆预订期间，埃文斯在19日午餐时间左右找到经理，要求多住一周。由于他们具有扰乱性的行为，经理只同意延长一天，并且在大约下午4点30分，看到利安在外面抽烟。那是他最后一次见到她，并且在她失踪的前后都没有关于争吵或可疑活动的报告。第二天早上8点，经理注意到埃文斯的皮卡不在停车场。它在大约下午1点重新出现，停在
administration office with Evans loading items into the back tray. The manager recalled seeing a second person helping, but couldn't be sure. Evans then told reception the family would be moving elsewhere. Her cleaner attended to the vacant room the following day, where she noticed two bed pillows were missing, along with their slips and protectors. Two fresh pillows were found in a cupboard, but were of a completely different brand. CCTV footage from April 19 showed Leanne visit the supermarket at 6.40pm, with transaction records listing her cash purchase of cream, mushrooms and onions. Three minutes later, she was filmed heading back to the Riverside Motel, with the Imperial Tavern camera across the street recording her return at 6.51pm.
administration office with Evans loading items into the back tray. The manager recalled seeing a second person helping, but couldn't be sure. Evans then told reception the family would be moving elsewhere. Her cleaner attended to the vacant room the following day, where she noticed two bed pillows were missing, along with their slips and protectors. Two fresh pillows were found in a cupboard, but were of a completely different brand. CCTV footage from April 19 showed Leanne visit the supermarket at 6.40pm, with transaction records listing her cash purchase of cream, mushrooms and onions. Three minutes later, she was filmed heading back to the Riverside Motel, with the Imperial Tavern camera across the street recording her return at 6.51pm.|||行政办公室附近，埃文斯正在把物品装进后车厢。经理回忆说看到有第二个人在帮忙，但不敢确定。随后埃文斯告诉前台，这家人要搬到别的地方去。她的清洁工第二天打扫了空房间，发现少了两个床枕头，连同它们的枕套和保护套也不见了。在橱柜里找到了两个新枕头，但完全是不同的品牌。4月19日的监控录像显示，利安于下午6点40分去超市，交易记录列出了她用现金购买的奶油、蘑菇和洋葱。三分钟后，她被拍到返回河畔汽车旅馆，街对面的帝国酒馆（Imperial Tavern）摄像头记录下她在下午6点51分返回。
This camera pointed towards the road and captured a portion of the motel yard. Silhouettes of several figures were recorded coming and going, but Leanne was not sighted leaving the Riverside Motel. This didn't necessarily prove anything, as the footage only captured the left side of the motel, whereas the couple were staying in a unit on the right. Furthermore, the cameras were shut down at 11pm while the system was backed up overnight, resuming at approximately 9pm the next morning. Leanne's friends and acquaintances provided further insight into her abusive relationship with Evans, with witnesses reporting that in the past he dragged her screaming by her hair
This camera pointed towards the road and captured a portion of the motel yard. Silhouettes of several figures were recorded coming and going, but Leanne was not sighted leaving the Riverside Motel. This didn't necessarily prove anything, as the footage only captured the left side of the motel, whereas the couple were staying in a unit on the right. Furthermore, the cameras were shut down at 11pm while the system was backed up overnight, resuming at approximately 9pm the next morning. Leanne's friends and acquaintances provided further insight into her abusive relationship with Evans, with witnesses reporting that in the past he dragged her screaming by her hair|||这个摄像头对准了道路，拍到了汽车旅馆院子的一部分。录像记录了几个身影的剪影进进出出，但没有看到利安离开河畔汽车旅馆。这并不一定能证明什么，因为录像只拍到了汽车旅馆的左侧，而这对夫妇住在右侧的房间里。此外，摄像头在晚上11点关闭，系统进行夜间备份，直到第二天早上9点左右才恢复。利安的朋友和熟人进一步揭示了她与埃文斯的虐待关系，目击者报告说，过去他曾抓着她的头发拖着尖叫的她，
and threatened to slit her throat. Leanne had also been seen with red marks around her neck, telling others Evans had choked her unconscious. This was of particular interest to detectives, as statistics showed women who are non-fatally strangled by their domestic partners are seven times more likely to be murdered. Investigators spoke with a former girlfriend of Evans, who explained their relationship started positively, with friends predicting it was built to last. She described Evans at the outset as a normal country guy and a dependable provider, who offered financial assistance to friends strapped for cash. Then one afternoon, as she drove an intoxicated Evans home, he punched her for the first time. She broke up with him,
and threatened to slit her throat. Leanne had also been seen with red marks around her neck, telling others Evans had choked her unconscious. This was of particular interest to detectives, as statistics showed women who are non-fatally strangled by their domestic partners are seven times more likely to be murdered. Investigators spoke with a former girlfriend of Evans, who explained their relationship started positively, with friends predicting it was built to last. She described Evans at the outset as a normal country guy and a dependable provider, who offered financial assistance to friends strapped for cash. Then one afternoon, as she drove an intoxicated Evans home, he punched her for the first time. She broke up with him,|||并威胁要割断她的喉咙。也有人看到利安的脖子周围有红印，她告诉别人埃文斯曾掐得她失去知觉。这引起了侦探们的特别兴趣，因为统计数据显示，遭到伴侣非致死性勒颈的女性被谋杀的可能性高出七倍。调查人员与埃文斯的前女友进行了交谈，她解释说他们的关系一开始很积极，朋友们预测这段感情会天长地久。她将最初的埃文斯描述为一个正常的乡下小伙子和一个可靠的经济支柱，他会向手头紧的朋友提供经济援助。然后在一个下午，当她开车送喝醉酒的埃文斯回家时，他第一次打了她。她和他分手了，
only to relent to his begs for forgiveness and reunite three weeks later. The abuse escalated and peaked when she lost their child from a neck-topic pregnancy. Evans spiralled afterwards, wrapping his hands around her neck and threatening to kill her. She took his threat seriously, as Evans was a gun enthusiast and owned several firearms. In 2001, she left all her belongings and fled to a friend's house, marking the end of her five-year ordeal. Evans continued to harass and stalk her until he moved to Queensland in 2007. A former cleaner who serviced Evans home told investigators of three threatening incidents in August and September of 2002. She reported him to the
only to relent to his begs for forgiveness and reunite three weeks later. The abuse escalated and peaked when she lost their child from a neck-topic pregnancy. Evans spiralled afterwards, wrapping his hands around her neck and threatening to kill her. She took his threat seriously, as Evans was a gun enthusiast and owned several firearms. In 2001, she left all her belongings and fled to a friend's house, marking the end of her five-year ordeal. Evans continued to harass and stalk her until he moved to Queensland in 2007. A former cleaner who serviced Evans home told investigators of three threatening incidents in August and September of 2002. She reported him to the|||但在他苦苦哀求原谅后心软，三周后复合了。虐待升级并在她因宫外孕失去孩子时达到了顶峰。此后埃文斯情绪失控，双手扼住她的脖子并威胁要杀死她。她认真对待他的威胁，因为埃文斯是个枪支爱好者，拥有几支枪支。2001年，她抛下所有物品逃到朋友家，标志着她五年来苦难的结束。埃文斯继续骚扰和跟踪她，直到2007年搬到昆士兰。曾为埃文斯家服务的清洁工向调查人员讲述了2002年8月和9月的起恐吓事件。她向
police after she found him waiting in his car outside her home, despite having never told him where she lived. As she never made a formal statement, she was unaware if any action was taken. Domestic violence orders do not appear on the respondent's criminal record unless they are disobeyed, meaning this information was absent from Evans' own record. When questioned about Evans' demeanour the day after Leanne disappeared, his friend Sam failed to notice anything unusual, although Evans was in possession of a brown handbag adorned with diamond-shaped patterns. Sam was able to describe the bag in intricate detail that far exceeded the rudimentary description circulating in the media, proving he had seen it
police after she found him waiting in his car outside her home, despite having never told him where she lived. As she never made a formal statement, she was unaware if any action was taken. Domestic violence orders do not appear on the respondent's criminal record unless they are disobeyed, meaning this information was absent from Evans' own record. When questioned about Evans' demeanour the day after Leanne disappeared, his friend Sam failed to notice anything unusual, although Evans was in possession of a brown handbag adorned with diamond-shaped patterns. Sam was able to describe the bag in intricate detail that far exceeded the rudimentary description circulating in the media, proving he had seen it|||警方报案，因为她发现他在她家外面的车里等她，尽管她从未告诉过他她住哪里。由于她从未做过正式陈述，她不知道是否采取了任何行动。家庭暴力禁令不会出现在被申请人的犯罪记录中，除非违反禁令，这意味着这些信息在埃文斯的个人记录中是没有的。当被问及利安失踪后第二天埃文斯的表现时，他的朋友山姆没有注意到任何异常，尽管埃文斯拥有一个饰有菱形图案的棕色手提包。山姆能够极其详细地描述这个包，远远超出了媒体上流传的初步描述，这证明他曾
in person. Electronic surveillance was later placed on Evans' mobile phone. It recorded a conversation between him and Sam, with Evans conceding he may have had Leanne's handbag with him when he visited Sam's home on April 20. As the investigation progressed, Kerry was unable to shake the feeling that Evans knew more about her daughter's disappearance than he was letting on. He looked her in her eyes and swore he had no idea where Leanne had gone. Kerry, quote, quote, I just had that feeling, that gut feeling. I thought he knows something, I know he knows something, but nobody could prove anything. After having been made aware that CCTV footage was available from the Imperial Tavern, Graham Evans agreed to participate in a formal police
in person. Electronic surveillance was later placed on Evans' mobile phone. It recorded a conversation between him and Sam, with Evans conceding he may have had Leanne's handbag with him when he visited Sam's home on April 20. As the investigation progression, Kerry was unable to shake the feeling that Evans knew more about her daughter's disappearance than he was letting on. He looked her in her eyes and swore he had no idea where Leanne had gone. Kerry, quote, quote, I just had that feeling, that gut feeling. I thought he knows something, I know he knows something, but nobody could prove anything. After having been made aware that CCTV footage was available from the Imperial Tavern, Graham Evans agreed to participate in a formal police|||亲眼见过。后来，埃文斯的手机被安装了电子监控。它记录了他和山姆之间的对话，埃文斯承认他在4月20日访问山姆家时，可能带着利安的手提包。随着调查的深入，克里始终有一种感觉，觉得埃文斯对她女儿的失踪知道得比他透露的要多。他看着她的眼睛，发誓他不知道利安去了哪里。克里说：“我就是有那种感觉，那种直觉。我想他知道些什么，我知道他知道些什么，但没有人能证明什么。”在得知帝国酒馆有监控录像后，格雷厄姆·埃文斯同意参加正式的警方
interview. His story remained the same, except for one detail. He stated he arose before dawn and drove to Kerry's house to see if Leanne was there, but the lights were off so he left without knocking on the door. As he drove away, the sun was rising, indicating it must have been around 6.30 to 7.00 a.m. In a subsequent interview two weeks later, Evans explained this return trip took him roughly 15 to 20 minutes and that he never exited his vehicle. Police had driven all possible routes Evans could have taken to Kerry's and back again, determining the longest took just 10 minutes. This revelation appeared to rattle Evans a little, but he stuck to his questionable timeline. Prior to her final departure, Evans claimed that Leanne returned from the
interview. His story remained the same, except for one detail. He stated he arose before dawn and drove to Kerry's house to see if Leanne was there, but the lights were off so he left without knocking on the door. As he drove away, the sun was rising, indicating it must have been around 6.30 to 7.00 a.m. In a subsequent interview two weeks later, Evans explained this return trip took him roughly 15 to 20 minutes and that he never exited his vehicle. Police had driven all possible routes Evans could have taken to Kerry's and back again, determining the longest took just 10 minutes. This revelation appeared to rattle Evans a little, but he stuck to his questionable timeline. Prior to her final departure, Evans claimed that Leanne returned from the|||盘问。他的说法保持不变，除了一个细节。他声称自己在天亮前起床，开车去克里的家看利安是否在那里，但灯是熄灭的，所以他没有敲门就离开了。当他开车离开时，太阳正在升起，这表明当时大约在早上6点30分到7点之间。在两周后的随后的采访中，埃文斯解释说，这次折返行程花了他大约15到20分钟，而且他从未下车。警方开车载着埃文斯可能去过克里家并返回的所有路线，确定最长的路线也只需10分钟。这一揭露似乎让埃文斯有些慌乱，但他还是坚持了他那可疑的时间线。在她最后离开之前，埃文斯声称利安从
supermarket with a plastic bag, but she never removed it from her handbag so he didn't see its contents. But during his second interview, Evans stated Leanne had purchased mushrooms. This raised the question, how he could have known if she never disclosed to him what she had purchased. Evans deflected, calling it an educated guess, as both he and Leanne loved mushrooms and often added them to meals. While their official stance was that foul play was involved, investigators had yet to uncover any evidence to support this belief. In April 2011, just short of a year since her disappearance, a fresh appeal was launched by Leanne's friends and family. A Facebook campaign titled Come Home Leigh was used to generate attention,
supermarket with a plastic bag, but she never removed it from her handbag so he didn't see its contents. But during his second interview, Evans stated Leanne had purchased mushrooms. This raised the question, how he could have known if she never disclosed to him what she had purchased. Evans deflected, calling it an educated guess, as both he and Leanne loved mushrooms and often added them to meals. While their official stance was that foul play was involved, investigators had yet to uncover any evidence to support this belief. In April 2011, just short of a year since her disappearance, a fresh appeal was launched by Leanne's friends and family. A Facebook campaign titled Come Home Leigh was used to generate attention,|||超市带回来一个塑料袋，但她从未把它从手提包里拿出来，所以他没有看到里面的东西。但在他的第二次盘问中，埃文斯却说利安买的是蘑菇。这就提出一个问题：如果她从未向他透露她买了什么，他怎么会知道。埃文斯闪烁其词，称这是一种有根据的猜测，因为他和利安都很喜欢蘑菇，经常把它们加到饭菜里。虽然他们的官方立场是涉及谋杀等不法行为，但调查人员尚未发现任何支持这一信念的证据。2011年4月，在利安失踪快满一年之际，她的朋友和家人发起了一次新的呼吁。一项名为“回家吧利”（Come Home Leigh）的脸书活动被用来引起关注，
with a post by Leanne's cousin Cassandra stating, It's unbelievable but true, as we all go on about our normal lives, a family still wonders every moment where Leanne may be. Leigh's son Bradley spent his first birthday two weeks ago without his mother. Although it may have been a precious moment, it could have been better. For others, this may just be another story, but the truth is, Leanne is someone's daughter, mother and sister. No one believes that someone can just disappear without a trace. We know somewhere there is someone with something. By 2012, having exhausted all lines of inquiry, the investigation into Leanne's disappearance
with a post by Leanne's cousin Cassandra stating, It's unbelievable but true, as we all go on about our normal lives, a family still wonders every moment where Leanne may be. Leigh's son Bradley spent his first birthday two weeks ago without his mother. Although it may have been a precious moment, it could have been better. For others, this may just be another story, but the truth is, Leanne is someone's daughter, mother and sister. No one believes that someone can just disappear without a trace. We know somewhere there is someone with something. By 2012, having exhausted all lines of inquiry, the investigation into Leanne's disappearance|||利安的表妹卡珊德拉（Cassandra）发帖称：“这难以置信却是事实，当我们都过着正常的生活时，一个家庭仍在每一分每一秒地猜测利安会在哪里。利的儿子布拉德利两周前在没有母亲的情况下度过了他的第一个生日。虽然这可能是一个珍贵的时刻，但本可以更好。对其他人来说，这可能只是另一个故事，但事实是，利安是某人的女儿、母亲和姐妹。没有人相信一个人会无缘无故地消失得无影无踪。我们知道在某个地方有人知道些什么。”到2012年，由于所有的调查线索都已穷尽，对利安失踪案的调查
officially went cold. In July 2016, the Cassowary Coast Police District underwent a change in senior management, with the newly appointed Chief Steve Kersley declaring Leanne Lappem's disappearance would be treated as a priority. Queensland's Homicide Investigation Unit was brought in to assist Innis Vale's criminal investigation branch as they reinvestigated the case. Graham Evans remained their main suspect, but it quickly became evident they weren't going to extract any new information from him. Instead, they focused on eliminating every other person of interest so a jury could see that all signs pointed to Evans as the perpetrator. The CCTV footage taken from the Imperial Tavern on the night of April 19, 2010 was reexamined,
officially went cold. In July 2016, the Cassowary Coast Police District underwent a change in senior management, with the newly appointed Chief Steve Kersley declaring Leanne Lappem's disappearance would be treated as a priority. Queensland's Homicide Investigation Unit was brought in to assist Innis Vale's criminal investigation branch as they reinvestigated the case. Graham Evans remained their main suspect, but it quickly became evident they weren't going to extract any new information from him. Instead, they focused on eliminating every other person of interest so a jury could see that all signs pointed to Evans as the perpetrator. The CCTV footage taken from the Imperial Tavern on the night of April 19, 2010 was reexamined,|||正式陷入冷案。2016年7月，卡索阿拉海岸警区经历了高级管理层的更迭，新任警长史蒂夫·克斯利（Steve Kersley）宣布将利安·拉帕姆的失踪案作为首要任务处理。昆士兰州的凶杀案调查组被请来协助尼斯维尔的刑事调查分局重新调查此案。格雷厄姆·Evans依然是他们的主要嫌疑人，但很快人们就发现，他们无法从他那里提取任何新的信息。相反，他们专注于排除其他每一个利益相关者，以便陪审团能够看到所有的迹象都指向埃文斯是肇事者。重新审查了2010年4月19日晚帝国酒馆拍摄的监控录像，
showing several silhouetted figures crossing the road from the pub towards the Riverside Motel. The Tavern had since gone into liquidation, but detectives managed to obtain staff logs and purchase records from its bottle shop and bar. They tracked down former employees and customers that night in an effort to identify those captured on CCTV. This was a large undertaking, as several people had since moved overseas, but eventually the detectives were able to account for every silhouette in the darkened CCTV footage, determining Leanne was not one of them. A task force was established to review over 100 crime stopper files and other reports to establish what information could be confidently eliminated from the investigation. Key witnesses
showing several silhouetted figures crossing the road from the pub towards the Riverside Motel. The Tavern had since gone into liquidation, but detectives managed to obtain staff logs and purchase records from its bottle shop and bar. They tracked down former employees and customers that night in an effort to identify those captured on CCTV. This was a large undertaking, as several people had since moved overseas, but eventually the detectives were able to account for every silhouette in the darkened CCTV footage, determining Leanne was not one of them. A task force was established to review over 100 crime stopper files and other reports to establish what information could be confidently eliminated from the investigation. Key witnesses|||显示有几个身影的剪影从酒吧过马路前往河畔汽车旅馆。这家酒馆此后已经进入清算程序，但侦探们设法从其瓶装酒商店和酒吧获得了员工日志和购买记录。他们追踪了当晚的前员工和顾客，试图识别被监控拍到的人。这是一项巨大的工作，因为此后有几个人已经移居海外，但最终侦探们能够弄清楚昏暗监控录像中的每一个剪影，确定利安不是其中之一。成立了一个特别工作组，审查了100多份犯罪制止者（Crime Stoppers）档案和其他报告，以确定哪些信息可以放心地从调查中排除。关键证人
were re-interviewed, many of whom expressed their opinion that Leanne's former housemate Orgy was involved. It was well known he had unreciprocated romantic feelings for Leanne and did not like Evans. Orgy was known to the Innisfail police, as he had worked with them for over 25 years towing vehicles from accident sites. During initial questioning, he was honest about his affection for Leanne and disdain for her boyfriend, having come to her aid after several altercations. Orgy claimed he last saw Leanne on April 16, 2010. She appeared happy, although commented she didn't like leaving Evans alone with the baby. During this meeting, Orgy declared his love for Leanne and expressed his interest in pursuing a relationship. He received a text
were re-interviewed, many of whom expressed their opinion that Leanne's former housemate Orgy was involved. It was well known he had unreciprocated romantic feelings for Leanne and did not like Evans. Orgy was known to the Innisfail police, as he had worked with them for over 25 years towing vehicles from accident sites. During initial questioning, he was honest about his affection for Leanne and disdain for her boyfriend, having come to her aid after several altercations. Orgy claimed he last saw Leanne on April 16, 2010. She appeared happy, although commented she didn't like leaving Evans alone with the baby. During this meeting, Orgy declared his love for Leanne and expressed his interest in pursuing a relationship. He received a text|||被重新盘问，其中许多人表示他们认为利安的前室友奥吉（Orgy）涉案。众所周知，他对利安有着单相思的浪漫感情，而且不喜欢埃文斯。奥吉是尼斯维尔警方所熟知的人，因为他曾与他们合作超过25年，从事故现场拖走车辆。在最初的盘问中，他坦承了自己对利安的喜爱和对她男友的蔑视，并在多次争吵后前去帮助她。奥吉声称他最后一次见到利安是在2010年4月16日。她看起来很高兴，尽管评论说她不喜欢让埃文斯独自和婴儿在一起。在那次会面中，奥吉向利安表白了爱意，并表示有兴趣发展恋爱关系。他收到了一条
from her later that night, but didn't hear from her again, which was unusual given she usually made contact at least every two days. When he heard she was missing, he contacted Evans to voice his concerns and asked to be informed of any progress in the investigation. Orgy's wrecking yard, Mundu Towing, was in the business of providing old cars to scrap metal companies. After collecting a certain number of vehicles, a car crusher would be transported from Brisbane to a paddock 500 meters from his property. Rumours circulated as to whether the car crusher had been used to destroy evidence and if Leanne was buried on Orgy's property. Although detectives were not convinced of his guilt, they understood the importance of officially
from her later that night, but didn't hear from her again, which was unusual given she usually made contact at least every two days. When he heard she was missing, he contacted Evans to voice his concerns and asked to be informed of any progress in the investigation. Orgy's wrecking yard, Mundu Towing, was in the business of providing old cars to scrap metal companies. After collecting a certain number of vehicles, a car crusher would be transported from Brisbane to a paddock 500 meters from his property. Rumours circulated as to whether the car crusher had been used to destroy evidence and if Leanne was buried on Orgy's property. Although detectives were not convinced of his guilt, they understood the importance of officially|||当晚晚些时候来自她的短信，但之后就再也没有听到她的消息了，鉴于她通常至少每两天联系一次，这很不寻常。当他听说她失踪时，他联系了埃文斯表达了他的担忧，并要求将调查的任何进展通知他。奥吉的废车场（芒杜拖车公司）从事向废金属公司提供旧车的业务。在收集了一定数量的车辆后，一台汽车压碎机将从布里斯班运送到他房产500米外的一块围场。有传言称这台汽车压碎机是否被用来销毁证据以及利安是否被埋在奥吉的房产里。尽管侦探们并不确信他有罪，但他们明白正式
writing Orgy out of the investigation. By 2016, Orgy was in prison for drug-related convictions. A search and excavation of his former wrecking yard was carried out, but nothing was uncovered to link him to Leanne's disappearance. Statements provided by a third party placed the spotlight back on Graham Evans, when police were informed that he spoke of having choked Leanne until her eyes rolled back in her head. On February 8th, 2017, investigators located Evans on his boat on the Johnson River. He agreed to accompany them back to the Innisfail police station to participate in another recorded interview, during which he adhered to his original statements from years prior.
writing Orgy out of the investigation. By 2016, Orgy was in prison for drug-related convictions. A search and excavation of his former wrecking yard was carried out, but nothing was uncovered to link him to Leanne's disappearance. Statements provided by a third party placed the spotlight back on Graham Evans, when police were informed that he spoke of having choked Leanne until her eyes rolled back in her head. On February 8th, 2017, investigators located Evans on his boat on the Johnson River. He agreed to accompany them back to the Innisfail police station to participate in another recorded interview, during which he adhered to his original statements from years prior.|||将奥吉排除在调查之外的重要性。到2016年，奥吉因毒品相关定罪而入狱。对其以前的废车场进行了搜查和挖掘，但没有发现任何将他与利安失踪联系起来的证据。第三方提供的证词将焦点重新放回了格雷厄姆·埃文斯身上，当时警方获悉，他曾谈到自己曾掐住利安的脖子，直到她的眼睛往上翻。2017年2月8日，调查人员在约翰逊河（Johnson River）的船上找到了埃文斯。他同意随他们返回尼斯维尔警察局参加另一次录像盘问，在此期间，他坚持了多年前的原始陈述。
When questioned about minor inconsistencies in his versions of events, he stated he was unable to recall. Although the evidence against him was mostly circumstantial, Evans was the only suspect remaining after the extensive police inquiries, and he was charged with the murder of Leanne Lapham. Evans' former cleaner, who had spoken to police following Leanne's disappearance, was interviewed for a second time. She admitted to not being completely forthright in her initial interview in 2010. Fearful, Evans would hurt her for speaking with police. She now admitted to having been intimate with Evans on one or two occasions in 2002,
When questioned about minor inconsistencies in his versions of events, he stated he was unable to recall. Although the evidence against him was mostly circumstantial, Evans was the only suspect remaining after the extensive police inquiries, and he was charged with the murder of Leanne Lapham. Evans' former cleaner, who had spoken to police following Leanne's disappearance, was interviewed for a second time. She admitted to not being completely forthright in her initial interview in 2010. Fearful, Evans would hurt her for speaking with police. She now admitted to having been intimate with Evans on one or two occasions in 2002,|||当被问及他事件版本中的微小不一致之处时，他表示自己记不清了。尽管对他的证据大多是间接证据，但在警方进行了广泛的调查后，埃文斯是唯一剩下的嫌疑人，他被指控谋杀利安·拉帕姆。埃文斯的前清洁工在利安失踪后曾对警方说过话，她接受了第二次盘问。她承认在2010年的最初盘问中并没有完全坦白。由于害怕埃文斯会因为她跟警察说话而伤害她。她现在承认在2002年曾有一两次与埃文斯有过亲密关系，
but they were never a couple. In late August, Evans tracked her down to her sister's house and asked her to come to his property to do some cleaning. Unnerved by his unexpected presence and tense demeanor, she refused and asked him to leave. But Evans grabbed her by the arm and said, you're coming with me. She broke free, and Evans then said, I've only come here to do one thing. He grabbed her by the throat and applied pressure. He spat in her face and threatened to kill her, only relenting when her sister emerged from the house and threatened to call the police. Evans left the property, hurling verbal abuse as he went. She initially hesitated to report the incident to the police as she knew Evans owned a gun and
but they were never a couple. In late August, Evans tracked her down to her sister's house and asked her to come to his property to do some cleaning. Unnerved by his unexpected presence and tense demeanor, she refused and asked him to leave. But Evans grabbed her by the arm and said, you're coming with me. She broke free, and Evans then said, I've only come here to do one thing. He grabbed her by the throat and applied pressure. He spat in her face and threatened to kill her, only relenting when her sister emerged from the house and threatened to call the police. Evans left the property, hurling verbal abuse as he went. She initially hesitated to report the incident to the police as she knew Evans owned a gun and|||但他们从来都不是情侣。8月下旬，埃文斯在她的姐姐家找到了她，并要求她去他的房产做一些清洁工作。由于他出人意料的出现和紧张的神情，她感到不安，拒绝了他并要求他离开。但埃文斯抓住了她的胳膊说：“你跟我走。”她挣脱了，埃文斯接着说：“我来这里只为做一件事。”他抓住她的喉咙并施加压力。他吐口水在她脸上并威胁要杀死她，直到她的姐姐从房子里出来并威胁要报警时，他才松手。埃文斯离开了房产，一边走一边破口大骂。她最初犹豫是否要向警方报告这起事件，因为她知道埃文斯有一支枪，
was proficient with a knife, having once seen him carve up a sheep. Despite her fears, she proceeded with the report and a domestic violence order was issued. She never saw Evans again. Soon after, she moved into state and changed her phone number, partly motivated by a desire to distance herself from Evans. Although she hadn't heard from him since, she remained fearful that he would find her again. In August 2017, new legislation was passed in Queensland Parliament titled, No Body, No Parole. This law required prisoners convicted of murder or manslaughter to reveal the whereabouts of their victims' remains in order to be eligible for parole. Adained to provide closure for families, applying to anyone currently incarcerated,
精通刀法，曾有人看他解剖过一只羊。尽管她很害怕，但她还是继续提交了报告，并下达了家庭暴力禁令。她再也没有见过埃文斯。不久之后，她搬到了州内并更换了电话号码，部分动机是想与埃文斯保持距离。尽管她此后没有听到他的消息，但她仍然担心他会再次找到她。2017年8月，昆士兰州议会通过了一项名为“不见尸体，不得假释”的新立法。这项法律要求因谋杀或过失杀人罪被定罪的囚犯透露其受害者遗骸的下落，以便有资格获得假释。旨在为家属提供慰藉，适用于目前被监禁的任何人，
withinmates told providing the information now will be taken into consideration when their parole applications were made. On September 19, 2017, Graham Evans appeared in the Brisbane Supreme Court to apply for bail. The statements provided by his former partners were presented along with a transcript of the text messages sent between him and Leanne, which displayed the volatility of their relationship. The court also heard that since his timing custody, Evans had been contacting witnesses and questioning them about the statements they made to police. Bail was therefore denied. On February 7, 2018, one year after his arrest, Evans' lawyer contacted detectives to discuss the possibility of a plea bargain under the
狱警告诉他们，现在提供这些信息将在他们提出假释申请时予以考虑。2017年9月19日，格雷厄姆·埃文斯出现在布里斯班最高法院申请保释。他以前的伴侣提供的证词以及他和莉安之间发送的短信记录被提交，这显示了他们关系的动荡。法庭还听说，自被拘留以来，埃文斯一直在联系证人，并就他们向警方做出的陈述对他们进行讯问。因此保释被拒绝。2018年2月7日，在他被捕一年后，埃文斯的律师联系了侦探，讨论根据以下条件达成认罪协议的可能性：
No Body, No Parole legislation. Evans would plead guilty to the lesser charges of manslaughter and interference with a corpse and to lead detectives to Leanne's remains in exchange for the shorter sentences imposed by these less serious charges. Leanne's family were consulted and although they had mixed feelings about Evans receiving less jail time, they sought to be reunited with Leanne after all these years. On February 27, Evans stood before the Cairns Supreme Court to formally enter his guilty plea. He then led police to a hillside covered in dense bushland on a private property in Cowley Beach, approximately 20km south of Innisfale, where he confessed to dumping Leanne's body eight years prior. Within just 20 minutes of the search commencing,
“不见尸体，不得假释”立法。埃文斯将对过失杀人和干涉尸体等较轻罪名认罪，并带领侦探找到莉安的遗骸，以换取这些较轻罪名带来的较短刑期。莉安的家属得到了咨询，尽管他们对埃文斯获得较短的刑期有着复杂的情绪，但他们寻求在多年后与莉安团聚。2月27日，埃文斯站在凯恩斯最高法院前正式认罪。随后，他带领警方来到考利海滩一处私人财产上覆盖着茂密灌木丛的山坡上，该地点位于因尼斯费尔以南约20公里处，在那里他承认在八年前抛弃了莉安的尸体。在搜查开始仅20分钟后，
the first of Leanne's remains were uncovered. Evans proceeded to provide police with his version of the events that transpired on the night of April 19, 2009, beginning with Leanne's supermarket trip to buy the remaining ingredients for dinner. While she was gone, Evans opened the fridge and found an open packet of bacon with a knife inside. He placed the bacon into a container and left the empty packet and knife in the sink. When Leanne returned and saw the items in the sink, Evans alleged an argument broke out and a struggle ensued. Evans overpowered Leanne and wrestled her onto the bed where he repeatedly punched and elbowed her in the head until she slid onto the floor. He left the room to smoke a
莉安的第一处遗骸被发掘出来。埃文斯接着向警方提供了他版本的事件经过，这些事件发生在2009年4月19日晚，从莉安去超市购买晚餐剩余的食材开始。她不在的时候，埃文斯打开冰箱，发现里面有一包开封的培根，里面有一把刀。他把培根放进容器里，把空包装袋和刀留在水槽里。当莉安回来看到水槽里的物品时，埃文斯声称爆发了争吵并发生了搏斗。埃文斯制服了莉安，将她摔倒在床上，多次拳打脚踢她的头部，直到她滑到地板上。他离开房间去抽一根
cigarette and when he returned 20 minutes later, she was no longer breathing. Panicked, he waited until it was dark before wrapping her body in a sleeping bag and placing it in his car. He intended to throw her into the river, but it had recently flooded and he realized that unless she was taken by a crocodile, she would likely float through Innesvale the following day. Instead, he hid her body in an area of dense bushland and a couple of days later discarded her clothing and phone in a river south of Innesvale. When Kerry heard that Leanne had been found, she almost fainted. Quote, I knew that she was gone, but I still had that little bit of hope that she might have just run away. It was closure. That's what I needed more than anything.
烟，20分钟后他回来时，她已经没有呼吸了。惊慌失措之下，他等到天黑才将她的尸体裹在睡袋里并放进他的车里。他本打算把她扔进河里，但河水最近泛滥了，他意识到除非被鳄鱼叼走，否则她第二天很可能会漂过因尼斯费尔。相反，他把她的尸体藏在一片密林中，几天后将她的衣服和手机扔进了因尼斯费尔以南的一条河里。当克里听到莉安被找到的消息时，她差点昏倒。原话是：“我知道她已经走了，但我心里仍然存着一丝希望，觉得她可能只是离家出走。这是一种解脱。这正是我最需要的东西。”
Even though it's hurting, it will always hurt. It's just that little bit of closure that I know where she is now. On March 21, 2018, the now 43-year-old Graham Evans was sentenced in the Townsville Supreme Court. His defense lawyer argued his client had showed significant remorse and reflected on the events of Leanne's death every day, stating, The difficulty of course is the initial panic and the lie. It's like getting on a roller coaster that you can't get off. The prosecution urged the judge to hand down the maximum sentence of nine years with no parole, arguing that Evans showed a complete lack of dignity and respect for Leanne, which shouldn't be discounted simply because he directed police to her body.
尽管这很痛，而且永远都会痛。这只是我知道她现在在哪里的那一丝慰藉。2018年3月21日，现年43岁的格雷厄姆·埃文斯在汤斯维尔最高法院被判刑。他的辩护律师辩称，他的客户表现出极大的悔意，并且每天都在反思莉安死亡的事件，并表示：“困难当然是最初的恐慌和谎言。这就像坐上了一辆无法下车的过山车。”控方敦促法官判处最高九年监禁且不得假释，并辩称埃文斯对莉安表现出完全缺乏尊严和尊重，这不应该仅仅因为他引导警方找到她的尸体而被折扣。
A victim impact statement highlighted the devastating impact Leanne's death had on her family, with Kerry telling the court her daughter's death left a hole in her heart. Quote, We were mother and daughter, but also best friends who could speak about anything and everything. I wanted to believe she had just taken off and could walk back through the door. I've lost a part of my soul that can never be replaced, and a part of my heart that will never recover. In sentencing, Townsville Supreme Court judge Justice David North described Leanne's death as senseless and brutal. Quote, It arose out of a trivial domestic argument that got out of hand and can only have done so because of an inability to step back and take account of or
受害者影响陈述突显了莉安的死对她的家庭造成的毁灭性影响，克里在法庭上表示，她女儿的死在她心中留下了一个洞。原话是：“我们是母女，但也是可以无话不谈的最好朋友。我愿意相信她只是离开了一会儿，还能走回门里。我失去了灵魂的一部分，这是永远无法替代的，也失去了心脏的一部分，这是永远无法恢复的。”在宣判时，汤斯维尔最高法院法官戴维·诺斯形容莉安的死是盲目和残酷的。原话是：“它源于一场失控的微不足道家庭争端，之所以会这样，只能是因为无法退一步并考虑或
control your anger. He acknowledged that while Evans had started with brutality, deception and lies, he had cooperated with the authorities. Had he failed to do so, Justice North stated his sentencing would be considerably higher. He cited Evans' lack of prior criminal history, reported good character and the shame he felt. He also accepted that Leanne's death had been unintentional and that Evans had taken full responsibility. Graham Evans was therefore sentenced to serve nine years in prison, with the possibility for parole after just four years, pending his performance during incarceration. Evans' plea bargain was the first case in Australia solved under the no body, no parole legislation. In a subsequent press conference,
控制你的愤怒。”他承认，虽然埃文斯一开始手段残忍、充满欺骗和谎言，但他确实与当局进行了合作。诺斯法官表示，如果他不这样做，他的刑期将会大大提高。他引用了埃文斯没有犯罪前科、据报道品行良好以及他感到的羞耻感。他还接受了莉安的死并非出于故意，且埃文斯承担了全部责任。因此，格雷厄姆·埃文斯被判处入狱九年，在服刑期间表现良好的前提下，只需四年即可假释。埃文斯的认罪协议是澳大利亚第一起根据“不见尸体，不得假释”立法解决的案件。在随后的新闻发布会上，
detectives encouraged anybody else in a similar situation to come forward to discuss their options with police, declaring the importance of returning homicide victims to their families cannot be understated. Evans lawyer Phil Renwick stated that Evans looked forward to doing his time and upon his release would go on to look after his and Leanne's son Bradley. Quote, I don't know what the child understands, he's fairly young, but it's going to come a time when Mr. Evans or some other family will have to explain it to Bradley. The circumstances of his mother's death reached Bradley's classmates at his primary school, where he was teased for having a murderer as a father. Kerry, quote,
侦探们鼓励其他处于类似情况的人挺身而出，与警方讨论他们的选择，并宣称将凶杀案受害者送回其家属身边的重要性怎么强调都不为过。埃文斯律师菲尔·伦威克表示，埃文斯期待服刑完毕，并在释放后照顾他和莉安的儿子布拉德利。原话是：“我不知道这孩子懂什么，他还很小，但总有一天埃文斯先生或其他某个家人必须向布拉德利解释这一切。”他母亲死亡的情况传到了布拉德利小学的同学那里，他在那里因为有一个杀人犯父亲而遭到戏弄。克里，原话是：
Imagine how a little six-year-old, seven-year-old boy feels with all that happening. Leaving abusive relationships can often be a slow process, with many survivors returning multiple times before separating for good. Some stay to avoid homelessness, poverty, custody issues, the shame of a failed relationship, or because they have been exposed to such prolonged abuse that their self-esteem has been severely impacted. Others have been cut off from their families, friends, or communities, leaving them with no support network to turn to, whilst others fearing no one will believe their partner could be capable of abuse. In many cases, survivors stay because leaving in itself can be dangerous.
想象一下，一个六七岁的小男孩在经历这一切时的感受。离开虐待关系通常是一个缓慢的过程，许多幸存者在彻底分居之前会多次返回。有些人留下来是为了避免无家可归、贫困、监护权问题、失败关系的羞耻，或者因为他们遭受了长期虐待，自尊心受到了严重打击。另一些人则被切断了与家人、朋友或社区的联系，导致他们没有支持网络可以求助，而还有些人则担心没有人会相信他们的伴侣会有虐待能力。在许多情况下，幸存者留下来是因为离开本身就很危险。
Violence often escalates when a partner attempts to leave, and it is during this time that most domestic violence-related murders occur. According to statistics compiled by not-for-profit organisation White Ribbon Australia, one Australian woman is killed by her current or former domestic partner every week, with indigenous women 32 times more likely to be hospitalised from family violence than non-indigenous women. Domestic violence is also cited as a major contributing factor to illness, disability, and premature death for Australian women aged between 18 and 44 years old, and is the leading cause of homelessness for women and their children. Australian police deal with thousands of domestic violence matters each week,
当伴侣试图离开时，暴力往往会升级，正是在这段时间里，大多数与家庭暴力相关的谋杀案都会发生。根据非营利组织“澳大利亚白丝带”汇编的统计数据，每周都有一名澳大利亚女性被其现任或前任伴侣杀害，原住民女性因家庭暴力住院的可能性是非原住民女性的32倍。家庭暴力也被认为是导致18至44岁澳大利亚女性患病、残疾和过早死亡的主要因素，并且是女性及其儿童无家可归的主要原因。澳大利亚警方每周处理数千起家庭暴力事件，
approximately one incident every two minutes. Not all forms of domestic abuse are physical, that can include stalking, emotional, financial, social, spiritual, and image-based abuse. Signs of an abusive relationship include perpetrators who humiliate their partner in front of others, monitor what they are doing, read their private communications, unfairly accuse them of being unfaithful, control what they wear or read, prevent them from practising their religion, or constantly criticise their appearance, intelligence or mental health. Silence and inaction are cited as reasons cycles of violence continue to perpetuate. It is encouraged to speak to people privately who appear
大约每两分钟发生一起。并非所有形式的家庭暴力的都是身体上的，还可能包括跟踪、情感、经济、社交、精神和基于形象的虐待。虐待关系的迹象包括施虐者在他人面前羞辱伴侣、监控他们的行为、阅读他们的私人通信、无端指责他们不忠、控制他们的着装或阅读、阻止他们实行宗教信仰，或者不断批评他们的外表、智力或心理健康。沉默和不作为被认为是暴力循环持续存在的原因。我们鼓励与那些似乎被困在虐待关系中的人私下交谈。
to be trapped in an abusive relationship. If someone discloses their experience with domestic violence to you, White Ribbon Australia recommends you listen with our judgement, offer encouragement and support, help the survivor discuss options, ask if they need assistance, contact a support service, and keep in touch to see how they are going. Respect their concerns and reassure them they have done the right thing by confiding in you and don't force them into making any decisions. Check with them first before you say anything to their partner as violence may escalate if they discover you have been informed about the abuse. Keep the information confidential unless children are involved and the laws of your state or territory require you to inform police.
如果有人向你透露他们遭受家庭暴力的经历，“澳大利亚白丝带”建议你客观倾听、提供鼓励和支持、帮助幸存者讨论选择、询问他们是否需要协助、联系支持服务，并保持联系以了解他们的近况。尊重他们的担忧，向他们保证向你倾诉是正确的做法，不要强迫他们做出任何决定。在对他们的伴侣说任何话之前，请先与他们核实，因为如果伴侣发现你被告知了虐待行为，暴力可能会升级。除非涉及儿童且你所在州或领地的法律要求你通知警方，否则请对信息保密。
In support of this episode, White Ribbon Australia provided case file a statement that read, Raising awareness is a critical part of preventing violence. Communities standing together and saying no to violence against women and children can encourage people to speak out when they see behaviour that isn't okay or to question their mate's behaviour towards their partner or even their own attitudes. Bringing violence against women and children into the spotlight is a key step in ending disrespect and violence. Carrie is waiting for the right time and place to scatter Leanne's ashes, explaining, I've got to let her be free because she was a free girl. She hopes Leanne's murder will act as a
为了支持这一集，“澳大利亚白丝带”提供了一份案卷声明，上面写道：“提高意识是预防暴力的关键部分。社区团结起来对针对妇女和儿童的暴力说不，可以鼓励人们在看到不当行为时大声说出来，或者质疑同伴对伴侣的行为甚至是他们自己的态度。将针对妇女和儿童的暴力行为置于聚光灯下是消除不尊重和暴力的关键一步。”卡莉正在等待合适的时间和地点来撒下莉安的骨灰，她解释说：“我必须让她自由，因为她曾经是一个自由的女孩。”她希望莉安的谋杀案能起到一个
warning to others to free themselves from abusive relationships, urging people to end things after the very first sign of violence. As Leanne would have never believed Evans was capable of escalating as far as he did. Well, if there is anybody out there that is going through with it, going through it, get out of it, go report it. There is always somebody around there to help them. There is somebody out there that can help them. Don't be scared. It's, yeah, you've got to get out there, mate. Don't be afraid. But it depends on how they've been threatened for, you know, like, you know, but still get out there and let somebody know about it. Yeah. You've got to open your mind, open your eyes and open your mouth more than anything, I think.
对其他人的警告，让他们从虐待关系中解脱出来，敦促人们在出现暴力迹象后立即结束关系。因为莉安绝不会相信埃文斯有能力升级到他所做的那种地步。嗯，如果外面有任何人正在经历这一切，经历这一切，赶快离开，去报警。周围总有人可以帮助他们。外面有人可以帮助他们。不要害怕。是的，你必须走出去，朋友。不要害怕。但这取决于他们受到了什么样的威胁，你知道的，但还是要走出去，让别人知道这件事。是的。我认为最重要的是，你必须敞开心扉，睁大眼睛，张开嘴巴。
Yeah. Don't let it go on any longer than once. Only that once, it's all you need. And there's a lot of people out there that would be thinking, oh, well, it was just a one-off, but it's never a one-off. Once they start, that's it. It'll just keep going and getting worse than worse. Well, I reckon if she had a, if she had a go on and had him charged the first time, I don't think this would have happened. But see, he was probably thinking, well, I've got away with it. I've got away with it this far and go even further if I want. But that's what I said. It's hard to know what anybody's thinking when this is all happening, you know, like, yeah, it's pretty hard. But I don't reckon she would
是的。不要让它持续超过一次。仅此一次，这就是你所需要的。外面有很多人的想法是，哦，这只是一次性的，但它绝不是一次性的。一旦他们开始，就是这样。事情只会不断恶化，变得越来越糟糕。嗯，我认为如果她当时去报警并第一次起诉他，我认为这一切都不会发生。但你看，他可能在想，好吧，我逃脱了惩罚。我到现在都逃脱了惩罚，如果我想的话，甚至可以走得更远。但就像我说的。当这一切发生时，很难知道任何人在想什么，你知道的，是的，这相当困难。但我不认为她会
have been dead now if she had a go on and seen somebody about it. She wouldn't even talk to me really properly about it, you know, because I used to say to her, you are right, like, yeah, everything's fine. Well, why'd you leave him? Oh, because he started maffin' off and rada, rada, rada. I said, well, that's fair enough. What do you want to go back for? Oh, I love him. And I said, hey, you can love somebody, but you don't have to put up with shit. It's not worth it, mate. Oh, yeah, you're over. Do you want to do something about it? Huh? Too late, mate. What does it take to get it through their heads? Don't put up with it. It's not worth it. You can only give advice by saying, don't be there, because it'll only get worse.
如果她当时继续跟进并去看望某人，现在就已经不在了。她甚至没有真正和我好好谈论过这件事，你知道的，因为我过去常常对她说，你还好吗，就像，是的，一切都很好。好吧，你为什么要离开他？哦，因为他开始胡说八道，啰里啰唆，诸如此类。我说，好吧，这很公平。你为什么还要回去？哦，我爱他。我说，嘿，你可以爱一个人，但你不必忍受狗屎。这不值得，朋友。哦，是的，你已经结束了。你想做点什么吗？哈？太晚了，朋友。到底要怎样才能让他们明白？不要忍受它。这不值得。你只能通过说“不要呆在那里”来给出建议，因为事情只会变得更糟糕。
It will get worse. It'll never get better. Imagine what their families would think, you know? They get bashed and killed and all that. They're not just losing themselves. What about their families? How their families are feeling about it or would feel about it? It's not a good thing to leave behind. But you know what? If it's not working, mate, whether you've got kids or not, don't be there. Don't put the kids through that, because they're the ones who's going to be suffering too. My daughter's dead now, and she was only 30 years old. Yeah. And there is younger than that out there that's copping her.
情况只会更糟。它永远不会变得更好。想象一下他们的家人会怎么想，你知道的？他们被殴打、杀害等等。他们失去的不仅仅是自己。他们的家人呢？他们的家人对此有何感受或会有什么感觉？留下来并不是一件好事。但你知道吗？如果行不通的话，朋友，不管你有没有孩子，都不要呆在那里。不要让孩子们经历这些，因为他们才是也将要受苦的人。我女儿现在已经死了，她才30岁。是的。外面还有比这更年轻的人正在遭受这种罪。
You know, there's help out there, but people don't, how can I say it? They don't seem to want to look to find it, you know? Go to their parents, go to a friend, go to somebody, you know? There is help out there. There is, you know? I just wish Lee Ann had it taken, you know, when I told her, you want to do something about it now, you know? Because otherwise it would just get worse. And look where it got up. You There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你知道的，外面有帮助，但是人们不，我该怎么说呢？他们似乎不想去寻找它，你知道的？去找他们的父母，去找朋友，去找某个人，你知道的？外面有帮助。确实有，你知道的？我只希望莉安当时听进去了，你知道的，当我告诉她时，你想现在做点什么吗，你知道的？因为否则情况只会变得更糟糕。看看它最终到了什么地步。本集尚无评论。点击转录文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。